[Music]
someone call 9-1-1 because Selena Gomez
is having so much festive holiday fun it
should be illegal hey Q I appreciate I
tried over the weekend Selena shared
this clip to tick tock belting out
Ariana Grande's Santa tell me with a
friend
[Music]
well it's all fun and reindeer games
until the camera pans to reveal her pal
in the back seat of the car hilariously
whipping out his phone to dial 9-1-1 we
hope everybody enjoys it Selena
captioned the post quote when the man's
call 9-1-1 on you honestly the whole
thing is so iconic that now all I want
for Christmas is a Selena Ari holiday
collab
[Music]
it's a very exciting thing for us but
this isn't the first time Selena has
proven she's an orientator on tick tock
that was Selena last year singing break
up with your girlfriend I'm bored word
for word
[Music]
and it didn't take long for Ari to take
notice she reposted it to her insta
story writing Cuties are you kidding it
was so much fun Selena has been serving
her fans some pretty epic content on
Tick Tock lately like this relatable
moment you need a job no I don't want oh
I know
what's your work in August she shared a
body positive message while on vacay
suck it in
I'm not sucking [ __ ] why real stomachs
is coming to my bag okay I think it's
the best for uh easy flowing Kinder
community on Tick Tock and back in May
the actress brought the LOLs mocking her
dating life lip syncing to Leslie man's
character in The Other Woman last time I
was single I was 24 and the dating pool
was everyone and now it's like a shallow
puddle of age-appropriate men who are
old and gross and I don't want to do
that safe to say Selena she has a good
sense of humor thank you in fact she
revealed when she had a kidney
transplant in 2017 as a result of her
battle with lupus she gave it a name I
named it after Fred Armisen why Fred
Armisen you ask because I love
Portlandia I love everything he does and
so what I'm so I'm like hey watch Fred
guys we're gonna be in slow motion like
[Music]
Selena gave fans an inside look at her
battle with lupus and bipolar disorder
in her documentary my mind and me Selena
Gomez was diagnosed with lupus
depression and anxiety
and she opened up to E.T about how she's
grown and healed from the experience in
a weird way I feel like it is it's a
time capsule I think it was really
healing for me to see that and get it
out I think and now that she got it out
cell seems better and happier than ever
[Music]
foreign